hello everybody my name is markiplier  and it's my birthday so join us today  for a charity livestream where we're  gonna be raising money for charity  I got weight here if you couldn't notice  and also Molly's up there say hi Molly  take a new you same old jag we did that  before okay so click of link in the  description below to be taken over to  the twitch channel where we're gonna be  raising money for the next few hours I  got a really busy day ahead so I I can't  go like all day but I'm still dedicating  the majority of my birthday to raising  money for this event even though there  are some hiccups um with the widget and  the event on child's play it's not  approved yet so we can't keep track of  the donations so just join us and give  whatever you can we'll celebrate it as  if you're doing it if you donated  millions anyway so thank you all so much  for watching and click the link in the  description below and I will see you  there bye